momento de hablar de economía quién
france24 me acompaña en el estudio
daniela blandón daniela comenzamos esta
crónica hablando de esa inseguridad
alimentaria que se ha duplicado en
honduras por supuesto por la pandemia de
kobe 19 hola santiago pues el programa
mundial de alimentos que como sabemos es
una agencia adscrita naciones unidas
reveló que antes de la pandemia del cobi
19 en este país es centroamericano de 10
millones de personas 1,6 millones
estaban en inseguridad alimentaria que
no quiere decir hambruna pero que sí es
una condición preocupante ahora son 3,3
millones que la padecen lo explica el
director del programa en ese país
las consecuencias son que las personas
tienen que reducir la cantidad o comprar
alimentos de menor calidad y de menor
precio
o comer menos veces durante el día pero
no estamos en una situación de
hambruna daniela esto sí que me causa
curiosidad el salvador ya cumplió una
semana de estar usando el bitcoin como
moneda de curso legal en ese país como
les fue pues santiago una semana después
la billetera digital creada por el
gobierno denominada archivo world ya
superó el medio millón de descargas
según el presidente nadie bukele el jefe
de estado también agregó que ya cuenta
con 50 cajeros en nueve ciudades de eeuu
ahora viene la parte mala los problemas
siguen afectando el sistema que el mismo
día de su lanzamiento colapsó y desde
entonces ha estado a menudo inactivo por
mantenimiento y esto no es para menos
santiago eso puede deberse a la gran
cantidad de los salvadoreños que no
precisamente quieren tener bitcoins sino
que quieren aprovechar el bono de 30
dólares que el gobierno puso en cada
cuenta para incentivar la adopción de
esta cripto moneda el mismo buque le
quien ha defendido el bitcoin como una
manera de recibir remesas sin
intermediarios ni comisiones reconoció
que la meta de tener listo el sistema en
tres meses quizás fue demasiado
ambiciosa y que se cometieron errores
pero que ya se están corrigiendo vamos a
ver cómo le sigue dentro danielle
hablemos ahora del estado de vermont en
eeuu que demandó a cuatro petroleras lo
que busca la demanda santiago es que las
compañías dedicadas a la explotación de
petróleo les digan claramente a los
consumidores que el uso de productos
fósiles daña el medio ambiente por medio
de avisos como los que usan las
tabacaleras para advertir sobre los
peligros del consumo del cigarrillo o
las empresas de alimentos que incluyen
información nutricional el fiscal
general del estado dijo que empresas
como exxonmobil cel sunoco y citgo
petroleum además de otras corporaciones
más pequeñas han venido engañando al
público sobre el verdadero impacto que
tienen sobre el planeta y no es el único
estado hay cinco más que han demandado a
las petroleras por su en el cambio
climático daniela una noticia importante
amazon contratará a 125 mil trabajadores
con mejores sueldos donde me postulo
donde me presento fue santiago se vio
obligado a hacerlo debido a que la gente
pues está cada vez comprando más
productos por internet pero también en
medio de una dificultad enorme de las
compañías en ese país para llenar sus
más de 10 millones de vacantes esto es
increíble la competencia por
trabajadores está cada vez más apretada
y eso ha presionado al alza los salarios
por ejemplo en el caso de amazon en su
salario base es de 15 dólares pero ahora
la firma dice que está ofreciendo un
salario inicial promedio de 18 dólares
por hora inclusive bonificaciones de
inicio de hasta 3 mil dólares en
ubicaciones específicas y otros
beneficios integrales así como acceso a
programas de capataz de capacitación a
ver si nos vamos para allá pues ya lo
saben buenas condiciones hablemos ahora
de indicadores o estoy de cerró en rojo
a pensar de que la cifra de inflación en
eeuu en agosto fue la más baja en siete
meses y mucho mejor de lo que esperaba
el mercado
en europa la situación no fue muy
distinta en españa la caída también
estuvo influencia desde luego por los
planes del gobierno de castigar a las
generadoras eléctricas para bajar el
precio de la energía y en américa latina
la bolsa de buenos aires recortó parte
de las ganancias que había logrado el
lunes después de las primarias
legislativas que golpearon al
oficialismo y para el cierre la cifra
del día daniel 54 mil millones de
dólares en ingresos agrícolas que planea
recibir australia en 2021 esto es un 10
por ciento más que el año pasado y un
récord histórico a pesar de la pandemia
de una plaga de ratones y de una álgida
disputa comercial con china australia
recordemos produce mucho trigo cebada y
canales se ha visto favorecida por el
alza de estos precios muchas gracias
daniel a la luz en negro en cámara
gracias a ustedes por la sintonía sigan
con france24